all right so
media matters
are our friends once again uh they're on
the case
they're on my case they're on daily
wires case uh here's the headline and
this is a long can't even read the whole
thing but
um written by arie drenin research
contributions from carly evans so they
got a team of researchers together for
this thing and the headline is on
facebook a dr phil episode about
non-binary identity becomes a bonanza
for right-wing
hate and then it continues
i feel like we need some sad piano music
in the background for this
right-wing figures particularly from the
daily wire weaponized a january 19th dr
phil episode to spread anti-trans hatred
and drive facebook engagement on their
posts
the episode posited non-binary
identities as up for debate and featured
non-binary people and allies alongside
anti-trans parents in the daily wires
matt welsh
media matters examined our data set of
news and politics pages on facebook and
found that among these right-leaning
pages were nearly alone in reacting to
the episode let's stop there for a
second of course of course right
why is that media matters why do you
think
it was a dr phil episode uh it's about a
subject that uh it obviously interests a
lot of people
people on the left especially very
interested in the topic of gender
and yet with this episode
as according to you because you've
looked into this only
or almost only right-wing pages even
acknowledged that it happened
why is that
um right link white right-wing pages
were nearly all known and reacting to
the episode driving more than 3.3
million views to one selectively edited
video in which walsh mocked the
non-binary panelists repeatedly asked
them to define womanhood that counts as
mockery now i guess just asking a simple
question
asking a question which is really what
do you mean
is mockery when somebody says something
to you and you don't understand what
they mean so you say what do you what do
you mean by that stop mocking me
no i mean maybe i would mock you i mean
it's i wouldn't put it past me to mock
you but first i have to even understand
what the hell you're talking about in
order to mock it
we haven't gotten past square one here
um
and uh and then walsh accused them of
trying to appropriate womanhood and turn
it into basically a costume that can be
worn i did say that
and then they get into they get into the
nitty-gritty here i mean they've really
looked into this they've got bar graphs
and everything here
uh with all of the interactions with
this vid with this video they're very
upset that anybody saw this or
interacted with the video um it says
from january 17th through through 24th
right leaning facebook pages related to
news and politics posted about the dr
phil episode far more often and earned
vastly more total interactions than
either non-aligned or left-leaning pages
uh and then it gives the actual full
interactions number interaction numbers
and it's all pretty good so this is a
great traffic i'm pretty proud of that
um
i actually didn't even know that the
video did this well on facebook this is
all good news for me
both shapiro and wall shared a video
titled leftist traumatized after meeting
me in which walsh mocked the non-binary
guests of the episode for sharing that
they had experienced nightmares and
depression as a result of their
appearance on the show
and then it continues from there
and this thing just goes on it goes into
their methodology
using crowd tangle media matters
compiled a list of
1773 facebook pages that frequently
posted about us politics from january
1st to august 25th and uh blah okay
very now what's the point of all this
why are they why are they doing all this
um
well it's not so subtle at all of course
this is them sending a message to
facebook like why hey you're supposed to
censor this you're not supposed to allow
this content out there
it's a it's a scandal according to media
matters that people on facebook were
allowed to see this video
and that tells you everything that you
need to know i mean through all of the
reaction to that dr phil episode
you notice what what what the left has
not done
they have not tried to explain why i'm
wrong i mean
none of them have
there has not been
that i have seen
one single article written
or youtube video posted or even tweet
that says oh you're wrong about what you
said matt and here's why
not even attempting to
because they know they can't explain why
i'm wrong and they also know
here's the real reason why the left is
not in even as media matters says
they're not engaging with this video
they just want it to go away
the real reason is that they know if
they if they try to engage with it the
first thing they're gonna have to do
is define what a woman is
if there's if they allow for if they
engage me in any kind of debate about
this
if they try to address it at all
that's the first question they're gonna
have to answer
is what is a woman and they cannot
answer it and they know they can't
tells you everything you need to know
um
they're not even trying to claim that
they won the argument they don't want to
have the argument they don't want you to
see it
that's the response to this
that's how you know you're really
on the right path
[Music]
when you say something that's uh
they're not even gonna kind of try to
try to shout you down they just
they don't want anyone to hear that you
said it
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated